Hey completely chose that apron comment
below or better the answer is pretty
clear oh yeah yeah I don't you can beat
this bacon today I'm worth it we're
gonna be trying three excellent forms of
bacon at three drastically different
price points to find out which one is
the most worth it at its price I'm
excited
bacon is a great food I'm not actually
that I said about an episode really yeah
this is overrated the smell and the
sound what the way it tastes I get it
but sometimes it's a little bit of an
overload I can definitely understand
that for this episode we are gonna be
trying three Bacon's not only at their
price points but in three different
cities roadtrip sky trip home trip yeah
we're going to Palm Springs baby hi my
name is Tara Lazar I own tikis
how did chi-chi's come to be I was
sitting in front of a computer day
trading and I really wanted a place to
eat breakfast I'm from Palm Springs so I
thought let's open a breakfast place
you're kind of famous I guess for your
bacon how did the bacon flight come to
be I like different kinds of bacon and I
didn't want to have to choose when we do
bacon flights we pick five different
flavors we change our flights every week
this week one of the flavors is miso
butter me so it has a really nice salt
content so when you make bacon you
typically need a salt and a sweet even
if it's not gonna be a sweet bacon the
other one is rosemary sugar that's fresh
rosemary and chop it up just put some
brown sugar and salt we bake almost all
of our bacon it's like the most even way
of creating a perfect slice of bacon Oh
what is your opinion on crispy versus
more such a crispy girl how about you
guys I do prefer a little bit of a chew
I still want to fight my food all right
so the crispy easy to easy to swallow
I don't sometimes doesn't get better
that food on the show should we try to
make them something that makes me feel
special
like things huh we're kind of the
breakfast experts oh okay why don't we
go to you okay I like that this feels
like science yeah Cheers
depart but delicious bacon time I kind
of like eating a strip of bacon with my
hand that go with that yeah I bought
some cat scratches okay I'm gonna give
the cat I don't but I indirectly cats
frequently I found a cat it won't be my
friend
Jews years
whoa I've never had bacon language
before that is great
neither chewy nor crispy it's to speak
it does taste like a warm bowl of miso
packed into bacon that's a good
appetizer yes let's bring out the next
month rosemary bacon Wow
Christy outside chewy inside there's
pockets of fat is ruling if everything
is when foods drool because they realize
how good they taste oh no that's my
favorite rosemary
top three herbs easily fully prepped it
that was like is it bacon you're pricing
a big another hat I can die happy now
time to take flight with the bacon play
Beeler apple cinnamon yes miso butter
rosemary sugar and a simple smoked one
also a halt opinion this has got to be
the way to go right so I'd be the
cheapest flight you've ever taken yeah
oh man oh that's the one
oh that's so good it's like the best
jalapeno kettle cooked potato chip I've
ever had
cause it's bacon Oh feel good so we
finished that one chirp or give it to a
Don
[Music]
that was an old man on the Adam scale oh
man don't say we never feed at him say
get some of that oh my god hmm oh yeah
one yeah LA in a minute the bacon flight
she's been doing it for ten years where
were you in 2007 at the prom
what telling yeah you were at prom I'm
not telling do you did 10 years ago
playing runescape why as a matter of
fact I was yo I picked chi-chi's I
already picked chi-chi's I really liked
ara
okay why are you laughing at that you
didn't like tera
bacon-fat what we call Canadian bacon is
actually pork loin or back bacon which
means that it's technically not the same
as u.s. bacon which is made from pork
belly makes sense because Canada is on
the back of America yeah American bacon
Canadian bacon you're looking at the
complete Pig right there so now we're on
our way to manuela getting something
called a BLT bacon lettuce tomato it's a
sandwich you know I accept BLTs news
flesh most people and except BLTs their
main ingredient is bacon
my name is Christian trunk I'm the chef
de cuisine at Manuela restaurant and
downtown LA what sort of restaurant is
Manuela kind of Spanish flair
I wouldn't say tex-mex but along that
line we do local ingredients our menu
changes daily depending on what we get
from the farmers market today we're
gonna be having your BLT what are all
the steps going into delivering that
dish getting the bread on the grill
little char on it so you got that char
flavor male tomato and some greens the
bacon you cure in house yes searing is
like this thing that I always hear
happens to food you're pulling a lot of
moisture out reserving that meat their
changes flavor texture so will you hear
it with salt sugar maple syrup for about
five days then wash it off air dried and
smoke it for about three hours I think a
BLT is just a simple but really good
sandwich so in this case we want to make
the bacon shine how much bacon is going
on this sandwich is like a pretty tall
stack or well miss five slices I think
it's just a perfect amount so what do
you have I have the prettiest Mitchell
lotta I've ever seen in my whole life
well cornichon rammed into an olive I'm
gonna name a cat cornichon some day in
my life I've never been a big fan dish a
lot of us it's a difficult taste to
acquire like if tastes were Pokemon
you'd need a master ball for the
Mitchell lotta Cheers fresh squeezed
fresh made oh yeah that's some good good
juice let's have this sample because I
watched this thing get made and I was
blown away favorite part of that process
usually the meat slicer name some people
aspire to own luxury cars you know your
mercedes-benz I want to pay a premium to
get that hand-cranked meat slicer let's
get this BLT
hmm I am sorry for all of the wrong
things I said about baking today baking
is good and not overrated this bacon is
at the perfect point between crisp and
tender draw a graph crisp tender it's
right on that line you toe off that line
when you look like a fool
pickle break well I love that pickle
it's a very good pickle what is the
shape of bacon it's like if you froze a
weird sound wave if a bacon strip was a
sound waves what would it sound like no
you do it don't it's wavy but not an
even wave we sound like a grandfather
talking to a child
well beating about the bacon bacon mom I
just ski Japanese for effect in Germany
bacon is called spec SPE CK that's a
spectacular fact in Netherlands bacon is
called spec but no see they spectacular
effect the French call it bacon or lard
and Italy considers pancetta as we do
bacon so now we leave Los Angeles to go
to the last bacon spot right in New York
City at the Gansevoort market
teleportation is real for our final
price point I'm a multi-course bacon
menu humble cos a woman sa I'm a seaman
Simon look I say
welcome to belly at Gonzaga market my
name is Johnny Wu I'm the executive chef
today you're gonna have bacon or Mikasa
and what is oh my god well Mikasa is
literally I leave it up to you so I'll
serve the best food around the pork if
you don't like it I try to like change
it radically and if you like the course
I just take the flow and what is your
background my background is a serious
home cook and this is the exactly same
setup it's almost like serving to my
friends and you know after the dinner
you become my friend very confident
I hope we're friends okay thank you very
much Kevin a cheers to the belly of the
pig so the first course of the day is
bacon sushi oh I like where this is
going and what's on top here what's up
cheers Stephen Cheers
it's good that's delicious I love seeing
food get made you start salivating in
anticipation and then there's no delay
is there pretty easy for the movies
this is bacon carpaccio I'm gonna wrap
it I'm just going
hmm what is that reaction we've had a
lot of crunchy bacon but this nice and
soft and luscious
that's so good mmm
I did not sign up for a salad but I will
listen to the chef in Korea
mommy's grandma always make food with
their hands so that's what I'm doing
with love you know we call it a hand
taste I'll tell you what my hands don't
taste good so don't get any R my hands
no problem oh thank you
hmm like a sesame vinaigrette so what I
would say it tastes like you ready for
bacon yes Cheers whoo I just had a
little bit of the mustard on its own
mustard is super powerful I love how he
immediately read us and then yeah he's
like already tinkering with something I
think I see a taco in my future come on
it's free it's a great chicken oh yeah
pop up one of this great
[Music]
accomodation the tortilla is actually
dumpling skin so it's a deconstructed
version of dumpling my mom she ran
restaurants when I was young I lived on
the second floor of that restaurant I
walk off by smelling food I think that I
mean it's in my blog I think thank you
carbonara
I needed this yeah it was like bacon
bacon bacon bacon pasta it's a good
break to happen every time Adam eats I
feel like I'm watching a David
Attenborough documentary this is a
dumpling okay you ready yeah
[Music]
well I just got this like wave of
nostalgia like eating dumplings in my
mom's kitchen the children is just like
kind of what she had to so if we came
again with the menu be different menu
really yeah do you remember that people
come here remember what you serve them
for sometimes I eat together drink
together customers I love that next time
2:01 at 201 andrew yes three Bacon's
today price points belly but you're in
the middle of this hectic market but
somehow it's this cozy at-home
experience but my worth it winner is
Manuela they have a dedication to
process and it's a super cool place to
be
Chickie's is my were that winner that
bacon was five totally unique Bacon's
Adam what's your worth a winner
can you believe that we've been doing
this for three seasons now I've kind of
developed the diet of a bear
force-feeding every day and then I go to
sleep for six months and I do it again
and that is the working season oh yes